let me get to Shea and Irving who joins
us now with his college picks for the
bowl games and twelve days of Christmas
oh are you are UK brothers piano I know
I didn't realize this I laid this track
down earlier you are a talented guy
that's me man
I like this but is it Linus or Schroeder
was it Schroeder who played the piano
Schroeder killed it Schroeder yeah I
like Schroeder all right you want to do
your 12 days of Christmas I do okay
right here is Shane Irving 12 days of
Christmas
on the twelfth day of Christmas the
roommate sent to me twelve packet Akane
leaven cartons of Lucky's ten outright
bangers nine ladies dancing eight Hall
Pass weekends 7/5 a jack what happened
to the song man six exit six packs alone
start all boys five pints of gin for
three-team parlays three backdoor covers
two nerds blogging and a ginger calling
the day of running game all right so we
got two ball games here we go put your
piano down very tough so Polly front row
is gonna have a bet with Shay here and
where do you guys stand on the money
from this all right by the way how was
that beer that I'm pretty upset right
now
why because I left beer here a few weeks
ago she did it's gone and I don't have
any now I got some warm beer words of
that Danny I can get Mario to get it I'm
waiting
forget the French kid to get the
Christmas hospitality I thought was
gonna be I know
stepped up a little bit and I apologize
you know what I'll take the blame should
alright so where do we stand with the
money you guys are up a couple hundred
bucks I think back three large three
large no no it's not three large but
you're up three Hyundai three honey
give me carry the one Paulie you forgot
those right Mario is bringing you over a
warm beer thank you thank you
it's a beer but it's a warm beer
whatever no okay so give me your picks
for the semi-final games okay hold on I
got Danny there's a lot more going on
here oh okay all right
I didn't know how many picks you had
oh no I'm alive okay okay I got a first
I want to lead with high school if you
don't mind high school pics yeah text is
a high school state championship game
you're gonna want to take Alan minus
seven and a half against our Lake Travis
there's only twenty third y'all and in
the Lido minus eight
yeah I hit them hard okay all right so
that's the Texas high school football
channel juggernaut yeah yep big day big
day night cuz I usually like Katy when
it comes to Katy ain't there Danny yeah
that pay attention yeah yeah less Lakers
you see there yeah what's like pretty
damn guy here we go alright so what else
you have fun can we go through the this
is how I survived Christmas so on the
22nd you're gonna take you a b-plus
seven you know twenty second CMU plus
three twenty third Toledo minus seven
the dollar general one of my favorite
stores the 24th Euston minus two and a
half and the Hawaii Bowl the twenty six
taking bill Schneider minus two and a
half and the cactus on the 28th okie
light - for camping world Bowl one of
the best and the 29th Utah State - four
and then on the 30th is you plus three
and a half in the Liberty Bowl that's at
Memphis against Memphis don't care and
then a New Year's Day Auburn I'm laying
the 10 against UCF and frost this final
game I like Agra as a pick'em Bama -
three Denny so you like Agra to beat
Oklahoma and Bama and Clemson is a
pick'em i poly front row on a piece of
Shea with any of them we're all set we
have one five-star we're gonna take
Oklahoma outright against you big boy
let's go let's go Baker's going down
what's at stake here
oh you double or nothing double or
nothing to have two for the season where
we let's say we don't even know where we
are did whatever whereas say let's say
we're at let's say you always 200 right
now okay double or nothing on the season
we'll take the Baker Mayfield against
Georgia okay how about a parlay - a
little surf and turf well surf and turf
I'm taking give me give me see mu + 3 +
ua b + 7 parlay it you got take you got
take Wyoming oh go on
so change Idaho Potato Bowl can I throw
Navy given getting a couple pick them
stop it don't try and hustle me he's
hustle G all year enough Danny I'm
trying to learn it's a new year's
resolution not to get hustled know more
about Paulie you know Shea after that
beautiful
somewhere in with whatever you want yeah
all right so so it's a three team to
team UAB plus 7 and C mu plus J 3 now
we're gonna watch this game and then the
Oklahoma George is just that's double or
nothing outright yeah okay no on it so
you give me three and a half to one on
that though parlez I'm not giving you
anything
oh yeah you don't have a piece of their
action oh oh dance a house danny's
exactly Danny come on why do you think i
gamble I know you can lose together but
he quits gambling who was as a
degenerate as you were nobody not never
but you're the reminder of what I don't
want to become again you kids out there
you can learn from this she thank you
it's it was great to have you stalking
us that you finally came to the hometown
of the trick show yeah just to be on the
show yeah that's it thank you we
appreciate it Thank You Shay
thank you all Happy Holidays to you and
the roommate and the babies for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]